ooh
[Music]
so in shot on site news o submitted by
Davis fan or if is a fun fan fun
probably fan fun a bipolar man
pretending to will the gun was killed by
NYPD oh [ __ ] that makes sense yeah that
makes perfect sense the headline makes
it yeah it's still Tannen
there's a lot of people that get killed
for holding toy guns and [ __ ] too
especially these things I made yeah
especially in a major city if it's like
NYPD LAPD there's just so much crime the
minute anyone calls we've got a small
town they're probably assess the
situation it's cuz you might already
know there's already a lot of cops that
got shot by people like ya a couple
years ago I'm on the highway here
Highway Patrol pulled over like this guy
that had warrants and stuff any we
walked up to the door he just got shot
and then drove away he shot the cop in
the face whoa yeah it's real even I
would too if someone broke into my house
and they did the whole like hand in the
gun I'm a hand in the jacket trick and
like y'all got a gun I'm gonna at least
let me just Amita start blasting that
for me you should know like yeah our
friend just shot someone our friend yes
he's a he's a he's a sheriff yeah not
illegally no the the person that he had
to shoot was reaching for my airsoft gun
when he told him don't like you know
don't move but he doesn't know it's an
aerosol yeah he didn't know it was an
airsoft gun he was a full-grown adult
but I think he used the airsoft gun
during a robbery
oh why would he reach for it I have no
idea I forgot that it was airsoft gun
yeah did you kill him
well maybe it's low yeah he's dead I
know pushed it out that sucks
yeah there's daddy's waiting I can't
wait to be cuckoo it's one of the old
bang
and it has a flag yes this dude here
eyes nameless ahed vessel and so he was
in Crown Heights and that's like he had
justice like ching-he from 2000 but then
like og done yeah so he was he was
holding this in his hand he was using it
like if it was a gun he was like going
what is that so it's like a tire pump no
it's so something about like a wielding
well a welding oh he probably doesn't
know what actual gun looks like yeah so
poor guy so he was like blowing like
this ham didn't have the video yeah
oh [ __ ] is a video I'm gonna show you
guys a video sucks man so [ __ ] [ __ ]
man the video when the cops pull up and
they could just see like it within
seconds they shoot him down but it's
like way up here and it's really hard
tell me and show you that but I'm gonna
show you guys what am walking around do
people report there's a goth again yeah
people are calling there are at least
three callers I see they're trying to oh
[Music]
yeah I would - it would have scared them
he's going out to people that have kids
- oh yeah if you get a call like that
yeah I'm shooting that [ __ ] no
people in this neighborhood are like
we're not blaming the cops man like oh
my God he's like that the cops they're
gonna show up are already on high alert
I'm sorry this is kind of muddy because
this will did it like 30 times joke is
played out - damn I said - what I
understand this one is the cop standing
there oh he's pointing it at the cops
come on dude that's like and then they
came up from this side cuz I could only
see a video where it's like hell he's
like a little kid playing a game that
nobody gives a [ __ ] about it with the
whoopee cushion is is putting under
everyone's ass like 20 times like we
[ __ ] get it the fart sounds funny
yeah and they're still doing it over it
it's like 40 years cuz that yeah if it
was if he was like a 8 year old with the
plastic red toy gun then that's kind of
different like you know because there
aren't even hella aggressive like he's
launching the week you know like the
popular because there are stories were
like there are children that has like a
super soaker and they get shot from the
cops right yeah so that's like obviously
[ __ ] up but this is the same thing but
he's a child in his head but in in but
when you see the guy he's a full-grown
adult and in aggressively moved into met
it's a piece of metal looks like it
looks like this yeah and then from far
away a metal pipe can shine and make it
look like yeah you know it looked like a
good he's like mad aggressive with the -
it's not like he's doing this good good
and he doesn't look crazy like like the
way yeah look like he's like homeless or
anything he just looks like stuck in a
year 2000 time machine that's all yeah
he just looks like a regular dude that's
like he's gonna go to work or [ __ ]
school there something he dressed up for
a cheney music video yeah ever left I'm
stuck in a time machine
is it paying yeah so like I said
neighbors are like you know what the
cops are doing their job but there are
some people are saying like they didn't
have to kill to do yes they do yep yeah
but that's always arguing you hear
though it's like the good a shot though
our mother lays all those dudes that say
that they need to do ride-alongs with
like Metropolitan Police can see all the
crazy [ __ ] that goes down a lot of those
dudes they get crazy prejudiced and
crazy like PTSD and one day cuz those
cops go through a ton of [ __ ] like shits
popping off all the [ __ ] time and
people are just yelling that from like
the comfort of their own home they don't
know the stuff I got to deal with
by the college junior here there was a
crazy guy that smashed up all the
windows and then can you have a machete
gonna axe get an axe and he smashed up
all the windows cops came and then I
actually made a video about this because
at the time I didn't have much knowledge
on how guns work right so this was like
this way when I still lived there yeah
this that wasn't recently that's even
like eight years ago or so it's like six
years
but back then I didn't own that many
firearms only had like a shotgun I
didn't go train frequently with a
handgun or anything like that but what
happened was they had a police dog they
had a Taser and then what the guy was
swinging his axe they shot some tasers
off him then where did it work he pulled
it off he kept swinging and then I was
thinking why didn't they just send the
dog right but then it's like that's
stupid because you can kill the dog with
the axe right so they didn't send the
dog they just shot the guy to death and
my logic back then was why didn't you
shoot the legs why don't you send a dog
why didn't you [ __ ] like tackle them
but then now that I know so much more
about pistols it's like you can't shoot
the legs it's hard as [ __ ] yeah it's
hard as [ __ ] to shoot a moving thinlit
like target like that you got to shoot
the body and you got to shoot enough so
they go down because it's like there
might be high the adrenaline yeah and
then I watch this documentary about
people doing PCP and they get superhuman
strength and that's when they started
moving the nine-millimeter to the bullet
size 245 during the 90s or something
like that because cops would run into
guys that are highest [ __ ] on PCP and
they'll do crazy things like break out
of their handcuffs they'll get thrown
into the backseat of a cop car and
they'll kick the door out when it's
locked
and in the bus yeah they'll do
superhuman [ __ ] guys would jump like
from three storeys high fall on the
ground get back up and start sprinting
yeah
yeah the kool-aid man yeah because of
that police started shooting to kill
like it was like I got a make sure that
the threat is completely gone because
you know prior to the angel dust and
[ __ ] whatever was going on in that
time
they didn't they never seen anything
like this they never seen superhuman
strength with drugs but I think the the
issue with this I'm because it's clear
he looked like he has a gun like that
but people they have residual anger from
all the unarmed black people that's what
it is yeah so they're not really
thinking logically it's just like you
did this because it was black but in
support of that there's all these
stories of white men with guns being not
shot and talked down and things like
that so the the problem is it feels like
you didn't even try but still with this
case like he's pointing it it happens
but 40 times - there's been a lot of
other cases where recently in Sacramento
that guy he was just in his backyard he
wasn't here oh yeah he got killed what
happened there yo man so like in
Sacramento like you know long story
short the guy was in they were looking
for somebody right and they went into
his backyard and the guy was on the
floor whatever would not like gardening
and completely unarmed I guess like he
had a phone and they thought it was a
gun or whatever and they blast him like
20 times while he's on the floor oh guy
that they were looking for don't even
know I'm not clear cuz I seen one video
and it made like it made the cops look
like they were kind of in the right cuz
it's showing from the helicopter you see
a figure you know I'm saying jumping
jumping and then it cuts to them in the
backyard with him you never see the guy
yeah you just hear them say gun gun gun
and start shooting then blam blam and
but it turns out there was no gun but
its darkest [ __ ] howdy
someone's watering their tulips and then
all of a sudden that comes but the cop
comes and [ __ ] shoots ya or some [ __ ]
that's crazy it just wasn't like the
right protocol it was just so weird
like in like I'm from Sacramento ii was
like super like culturally diverse like
just like the asian like asian-american
black american populations is huge so i
hear something like that that happens in
sacramento it's just so odd for me yeah
i mean like it's not like la you know my
thing la is very culturally diverse was
very segregated in sacramento it's not
like that and so like that for
sacramento people when they see that
happen it's not gonna go quiet it's not
one of those things that every time yeah
we don't like push it under the rug like
it's more like yo what the [ __ ] that's
our backyard and it's a small town - so
you can't get away with that [ __ ] and
everybody supposed to be cool with it
so it was like it was super sad man but
I just don't understand I think the
protocol was wrong like even if like
somebody's hopping over the fence like I
don't know I think there's just like
inherited fear of black people
especially now because they know we're
angry at the police so it's like I'm on
heightened alert because you're on
heightened alert and then there's no
there's no middle exchange initiatives
but whack my buddy used to patrol the
the south-central area like he's not in
that area now which is predominantly
black and Latino right yeah
but he's he was like basically he
there's a shootout every day but he says
it's like black on black crime like it's
not against the police he doesn't feel
like scared for his life on a daily and
he says he answers a lot of calls where
it's like domestic violence or whatever
and in most shootings and things like
that is just happening within like
family fighting or whatever so he
doesn't he didn't he told me that he
doesn't feel the tension but then other
rookie ass cops that come in and they
don't understand the community they
don't understand the people they have
yeah so that that kind of tension is
like oh [ __ ] but he's like the smart
cops that last a while they know like
you got to just get to know people and
then you got to play politics and you
just got a you just got to understand
but he says the guys that are constantly
afraid they don't last long yeah yeah
but that's you know that's the worst
part of town though that's not like to
say like that's all of black community
or anything like that that's just what
he told me from policing that area
[Music]
[Music]